[Music]
okay hi everyone and I'm glad to be in
the company of other language teachers
but the points that I'm going to talk
about and mention today don't really
have anything to do with campus with the
language so hopefully they'll be useful
to everyone so like many of you when we
first started using canvas I had this
huge fear of like oh my god this is
going to be a huge waste of time I'm
going to have to spend so much time
learning how to do this I'm going to
have to spend so much time putting all
my teaching resources on it this is a
new whole new learning process so what
I'm going to talk about today is like
things that I did in order to save time
and cut on time and things that I know
students appreciate it because not only
did it save me time but it saved them
time as well so I'm going to start from
the beginning and I'm sure you're
familiar with this picture this is what
we see when we first learn to log in to
canvas and you can see that we started
the tabs for the classes and the way to
tell one class from the other is the
color I don't know about you but about
as far as I'm concerned a number of
times I clicked on the wrong box and I
found myself in the wrong class and I'm
like no this is not at all what I want
to do and I have to go back a couple of
steps to enter an easy way to solve this
problem is if you personalize your class
and put a picture as to what each class
looks like so these are two of the
classes that I'm teaching this semester
each one has a picture it's a lot easier
for me to click on the right picture
when I want to go to the right class and
also as far as the students is concerned
because like you they have like four or
five tabs that are only different in
color but now when there's a picture to
your class they can easily identify and
access it quite easily another thing
that I found useful and saved me a lot
of time is using the calendar we've
heard already a couple of our presenters
mentioning different techniques of using
canvas calendar is one of them certainly
is not the only one
is where calendar is if you haven't used
it and when you click on it you can go
to the calendar and what you can do is
for every day or for every week or
multiple times a day you can set up
different events and what I do is I
start early before the beginning of the
semester I go to the calendar and I put
in every single test or quiz or a
writing assignment or grade of grading
activity or even activities that are not
graded that might be of importance to
the student and when you go to the
calendar when you click on each day this
is the tab that you're going to get what
allows you to put in either an activity
or an assignment and the details and the
link and the time etc etc the other
thing that you can do from the same
calendar is you can have it assigned to
two different classes or three different
classes for that matter as a language
teacher I teach multiple sections so
this is useful I don't have to do the
same thing again rather all I have to do
is change the class and add it to the
calendar of that class the other amazing
thing once I'm done on the main page of
what the students see they can see as
you can see right here all the times all
the activities that I've set up in the
calendar they're all there nicely
yeah arranged to chronologically so they
know when they have a test and when they
have quiz they don't need to ask me I
don't need the answer everybody's saving
time another nice thing about calendar
is that you can actually synchronize it
so if you click on this tab over here
you'll find out that there is an option
that you can add all these dates to your
Google Calendar whatever your personal
Google Calendar is you can add so this
is what you would get and if you take
the link and add it to your Google
Calendar all these dates will be added
to your Google Calendar so the students
can go that's especially helpful for the
students because they have other events
and other classes and other stuff that
they have to do this way they
see everything on their Google Calendar
without having to ask me and I don't
have to answer the other thing that I do
that saves me and the students time is I
use assignment and when I set up
assignments I give each one of them
value depending on category and when I
do that again through the magic of
canvas they can see on their first page
on the on the front page of the class
they can see exactly what are the graded
items that they have to go through and
how much each of them is worth yes we
have a syllabus in the syllabus we put
all this thing together but it's nice
for them through one-click as soon as
they sign in they can see all these
information without having to ask the
other advice that I have for everyone I
have been teaching for a while and I
have developed a number of teaching
resources and I found out using canvas
that there's always a way to embed
materials that you have had from the
past you don't need to do it again you
don't all you have to do is ask someone
or get the advice of someone and there's
always a way to embed your previous
materials I have successfully been able
to embed videos other teaching materials
that I've used in the past from other
technological resources and again I
teach elementary or at least I'm
teaching elementary this year so a lot
of my teaching material came from
different resources and I was successful
in embedding all of them and this
enables me to use it on the site for the
students as assignment or as homework
but even in the class it has been quite
useful and quite helpful and I didn't
have to change a whole lot of my
teaching materials so these were just
some tips from me that I hope that it
will save you some time and also save
your students some time which they will
appreciate thank you very much
[Applause]
and questions yes when you set up the
calendar do you have to do it every year
or you can't navigate it no no I'm
afraid you have to do it every semester
because the way I do it is depending on
the date that's why you can't move it
from one semester to the other it's yes
I set it up by the the dates that the
dates for the quizzes and the tests and
the written assignments if I set up the
calendar for my course from the student
perspective if they have a number of
different courses does their calendar
then show things from all the different
courses with different colors yes that's
exactly a complain that they can't
figure out what we how to sync their
lives up they have a way of doing that
if we've helped them by putting it on
the calendar yes exactly yes so whatever
items there are on the canvas calendar
they they will be different with
different colors and when you hover the
mouse over it it'll tell you the name of
the class like let's say they're not
sure what which class is the pink color
if you just hover the mouse over it it
will tell you which class that is canvas
tools do you use for to embed the
examples that you gave here for example
do you use assignments do you use the
quizzes
I've been able to embed stuff in assign
mostly assignments but also in the pages
and even on the front page I've been
able to embed stuff absolutely
calendar do is it possible for students
to like click on the event and have it
go directly to canvas yes yes absolutely
if it is something that will take that
is linked to an assignment or a quiz yes
it'll take them there right away
absolutely yep today because I use it
not only for my written quizzes if the
quiz is sellable in chronically you can
import in import from here to here and
the dates will adjust for you so it
automatically adjusts is beautiful you
don't have to do it by hand but presume
you don't want to put all your tests on
canvas so then it depends what you do if
you have say oral presentations
assignment then I believe again as long
as the date is given like today we hit
orals and the there is a tab submit
required submissions so that means when
I import resources for next year
the date will adjust for me in other
words it will still be that assignment
on Tuesday of whatever the new date it
will automatically adjust so yes you
will depends what type like the lights
fellow presentations obviously that you
have to input by hand but are the events
it will import so you don't have to do
all of it by hand
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]